من المؤكد أن مقطع فيديو رائعًا
قدمه الجنرال الأوكراني
فاليري زالوشني ، يبدو أنه يُظهر
الجنود الأوكرانيين يستعدون
للمعركة ويقولون إن الوقت قد حان لاستعادة
ما لدينا الآن في الفيديو ، ما
تراه أيضًا هو أنهم يظهرون الكثير من
الغرب  تم توفير معدات عسكرية
تتراوح من مدافع الهاوتزر التي زودتها الولايات المتحدة إلى
نظام إطلاق صواريخ متعددة عالية على المريخ ، ولكن أيضًا زودت ألمانيا
دبابات القتال الرئيسية Leopard 2 والتي يعتقد الكثيرون
أنها ستكون عنصرًا رئيسيًا بمجرد أن
يبدأ الأوكرانيون هجومًا مضادًا
يلوح في الأفق لفترة من الوقت  الآن من
غير الواضح ما إذا كان هذا يمكن أن
يكون مؤشرا على أن
الهجوم المضاد قد يكون في
الأفق قد يقترب قليلا ولكن
أحد الأشياء التي نراها هو أنه
يبدو أن هناك عددًا متزايدًا
من الضربات بعيدة المدى ربما بواسطة
الأوكرانيون في الجزء الخلفي من
الروس يركزون الآن بشكل
أساسي على مكانين أحدهما
بيرديانسك على البحر والآخر
هو ماريوبول وهو بالطبع
مدينة ساحلية رئيسية على البحر وكذلك
في الواقع هناك  هي تقارير عن ثلاثة
انفجارات على الأقل في استطلاع ماريو
يوم السبت ، ماريوبولي هي واحدة من
قواعد الانطلاق الرئيسية للجيش الروسي
لعملياتهم في أوكرانيا ، لذلك
بالتأكيد يمكن أن يكون ضربة كبيرة
للروس إذا كان الأوكرانيون
يضربون بالفعل تلك المنطقة الروس  من
جانبهم يقولون إنهم
اعترضوا بعض الطائرات بدون طيار الأوكرانية وبعض
الصواريخ الأوكرانية أيضًا ،
وكانوا يتحدثون أيضًا عن اعتراض
صواريخ ستورم شادو التي
زودتهم بها المملكة المتحدة
بالطبع.  كما لو أن
الروس في هذا الجزء من أوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي
يبدو أنهم يتعرضون لقدر كبير
من الضغط من أجل pleiken CNN Kiev